I'm in a hotel room no follow-up
questions hi my name for yourself you
don't know now you know you're like the
zipper now I'm traveling so I thought I
would make a stream of consciousness
style video for you guys today we've
been done one of those in a second
taking a second Oh Falcon super moment
there's a helicopter or plane engine
inside I brought you Superboy learn two
very important things one I never want
to not be transported to a place I need
to be without being carried by maybe
straight male backup dancer and to
Giselle is a really good impression of
animal from the Muppets but that lady
got a halftime show though I know in the
privacy of your own hotel room you could
feel sucks toast it was like when you're
in your car and you pretend you're on a
phone call but really you just have an
amount of breakdown to yourself they're
really staring hard haven't ever seen a
31 year old woman set up a small camera
on an ironing board in her hotel room
and speak out loud to it while she moves
from side to side to create a more
visually interesting jump cut no I've
never seen that before
okay I feel totally vulnerable at all
whatsoever would you guys sing at the
halftime show I thought it was out she's
standing she can sings dance
it could be weird to still be
universally loved and adored and
appreciated for just undeniable talent
into it I missed out on the puppet ball
though how was that I heard it was a
little rough oh my god I got myself a
sushi burrito from Whole Foods that
choice wasn't good unlike the quality
that comes in this is YouTube video hey
Debbie way what are you guys super
Ballantine's day oh cool
same oh but that's not how the armrest
works I took my extensions out a short
here no this is fun because I feel like
I look closer to my age let's see what's
happening in the world Harambee shape
cheeto is currently going for $100,000
what is this fevered dream that we are
all currently trending headline does
Donald Trump own a bathrobe what I'm
okay never knowing the answer to that
wearing sneakers with heels I had a
natural energy drink Cheers this is
called perps it's got a little legs on
it like I think the perps is like the
coolest lying way to say perhaps you do
anything fun for Valentine's it's your
perps perps game here for sure
from this earth all right contains 32
percent juice what my favorite
percentages Lily my throat tried to
close itself off before I could swallow
this my body loves perps there's a door
in this hotel room right here it doesn't
actually have a doorknob potential daddy
closet cute a lot of interesting choices
in this hotel room would you care to see
of course you have no choice in this so
here's my setup ooh
you remember perps from a couple minutes
ago is the coffee table situation this
rectangular piece of thing with a coffee
table over top of it and I don't fully
understand what anything is that's
happening here then we got this pattern
Raj is just a nice not anxiety inducing
clash of fabrics I'm very curious the
home I to judge you know who is to judge
that woman across the window Oh mamrie
had a barbecue over the weekend if you
don't follow me on snapchat you missed
some real quality moments okay my
battery's gonna die hey Thank You
universe for an actual sign that I
should stop this is kind of an mm-hmm
video sorry it wasn't more like I wasn't
back in LA I'll get back to our regular
scheduled programming until then give
this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
at all whatsoever
and click this button to subscribe to
this YouTube channel because Monday
Wednesdays and Fridays mhm we're around
having times making beds just trying to
get by that do anything I need to
promote or any other self-serving
messages I need to put out there for you
guys
nope okay sushi burritos